[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
happy
hump day
today is wednesday
i don't know if wednesday is the best
day of the week
but it starts
the best day of the week i don't know
maybe friday's the best day saturday
sunday i don't know what do you guys
think
i like hump day
that's because i can say hump day i
guess i don't know i don't know happy
happy happy hump day to everyone out
there and everyone's here gail's here
hello jay's here carter's here robin's
here patty is here kathy's here david's
here
leah's here debbie salt lake is here
good morning good morning good morning
all let's play some good morning
messages here from everyone
it's very good to see all of you
here at the show with the tony michaels
podcast
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central right here on youtube twitter
twitch as you guys know we have joined
the midas media network which is really
cool we're super excited about that um
it'll grow our audience i know so
anytime anytime you guys think that you
have a friend out there that would like
to listen to the show please send in the
link
to the youtube link and have them
subscribe to the channel so they do not
miss an episode because they can listen
live
just like some of you guys do which they
can get into the chat
which we have
we have some news about the chat we have
super chat now i don't know if you guys
know what super chat is if anyone
doesn't know what super chat is tell
them in the chat what the super chat is
but we have super chat now
so thank you to everyone who
participates in the show who comes every
day who sends dms who keeps us
abreast to the breaking news as we're on
the show because what you see is what
you get
it is me
and gabe that is it behind the uh the
camera here there's no special effects
no big huge
uh
board or person that's running the show
it is us
it is us
so thank you very much for supporting us
thank you very much to the mizella's
brothers for
uh bringing us to
the midas media network and i always
have enjoyed the midas mighty joining us
here on the podcast we've always
had the mind as mindy joining us here
they are a great group of people and
anyone who isn't midas mighty that is
our audience hopefully hopefully you
will discover
that of what a great group the mind is
mighty is
and maybe maybe today uh we'll have
someone on i i don't know yet if if
they'll have time to come
talk about legal af they do a wednesday
episode now legal af
along with their saturday episode so
um welcome welcome welcome to everyone
uh midas marge says welcome uh
robin says the [ __ ] family that's
right the [ __ ] fam
that's right we're the [ __ ] fam here
you know an extension like an extension
like a sub group
now of the mind is mighty like there's
the minds mighty and then there's the
[ __ ] fam
hopefully everyone in the midas money
will be part of the [ __ ] fan
eventually
so um we do we do have um
some some more
announcements gabe's gonna join us at
the bottom of the hour as as as normal
uh christina thank you for the super
chat
the super sticker thanks for the super
sticker
there
if you guys want to get in on the super
chat you do that and i'll i will try my
best to notice
the super chat as you guys do that and
bring you up on the show
uh thank you thank you very much for
supporting the show it means a lot to us
uh we we take a lot of time and a lot of
effort and a lot of thought into the
show
um i really think that's um
great that you guys support us not just
coming here but also um the likes the
retweets the shares
not not just on twitter either we're on
the instagrammies
i don't know if you know me and gabe are
over on the instagrams and we're also
we're on tick tock too so if you're
supporting us over there we thank you
thank you a lot i've been trying to post
more on the grammy grams and the tiki
talks
but you know we have a very soft spark
spot in our heart on this show for the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends but
the grammy grams and the tiki tax
we will try to do those more and more
um as as as we do more shows so thanks
for joining us today we do have a long
list of stuff to get to today
ah let's see it looks like prince john
is trending i'm not sure who the [ __ ]
prince john is have you figured this out
do you think that bonehead
has any idea who prince john is or what
she's talking about we'll we'll try to
we'll try to unravel that
that a bit of dribble um we're also have
a lot of um news coming out of
uh ukraine
um there's an idaho law that's being
passed of course these fascists have to
out fascist the other fascist you know
texas has to out florida florida florida
has to out texas texas now idaho has to
has to out florida florida
i don't know it's it's going to continue
um if and if you want my personal
opinion i believe that these fascists
are not going to stop
at
not allowing children to say the word
gay and not not they're not going to
stop
at trans children they're not going to
stop at the parents of trans children
the siblings of trans children they're
not going to stop there
they are after your children
100 that's what the crt [ __ ] was last
year they made it clear they're going to
target children in this country the
fascist
that is their goal that is what they
want
and boy are the fascists excited that
they're doing it they are super excited
that they're doing it uh we also have an
executive order
that we want to talk about this morning
i think it has to do with crypto
cryptocurrency i believe
so elon musk is probably really really
upset
at brandon this morning i'm sure and
[ __ ]
and [ __ ] rube
i don't know if uh
if the venn diagram of our audience and
elon musk little fanboy base um you know
has any kind of you know uh
if it's the same or not i doubt it i
seriously doubt it so [ __ ] elon musk i'm
not a fan of elon musk i don't know if
you notice that
um i say right now in a time of war and
the time of war what the president
should be the executive order that the
president should be writing is to tax
elon musk jeff bezos uh
bill gates all the billionaires in our
country tax them 120
for the next i don't know 6 8 10 months
and all that money should go towards
inflation protection
and uh gasoline price protection i don't
know i'm just saying
they're saying it might be a good idea
we could do that we could do that we
might not probably won't but we could
[ __ ] them um we also have bank of
america trending you guys see this story
i haven't read exactly this story but
apparently
apparently um
they confused
a the director of black panther
with another black person i i can't i
can't understand
oh boy
oh boy what what a [ __ ] show that is
gonna be when we talk about bank of
america i'm sure when we get to bank of
america and the twinny trends and the
tweety tweets on the [ __ ] list roundup
it's gonna be
a great story i'm sure
i'm sure it will be
uh
so um
what else do we have here on the um
it looks like their um russia has
um
reneged on their ceasefire and they
actually i believe they bombed and
destroyed a hospital
um
obviously um it is a signal being sent
by the russian army and vladimir putin
that murderous [ __ ] dictator
and anyone
anyone out there that is not aware that
these republicans have [ __ ] the bed on
this putin thing and we need to hold
them accountable right we cannot let
them get away we cannot let them get
away with they supported putin
but now that he's bombing hospitals
during a ceasefire oh well
he's he's evil
he's a tucker carlson he may be evil but
he may be evil but shut the [ __ ] up
that's enough of that [ __ ]
we need to hold them accountable for
every single statement every single
pro-putin thing that they've said
the continuation
of appeasing putin because that's what
they're doing and that's what they've
been doing and they keep propagating
russian propaganda anti-democracy
propaganda
it's a bunch of [ __ ] nonsense and we
need we need to hold them accountable
and i'm not just talking about the
politicians folks
it does not just stop at the [ __ ]
politicians like ron johnson marco rubio
lindsey graham
tucker carlson that [ __ ] sean hannity
donald trump it doesn't stop
there your neighbors your friends your
community members they need to
understand
they need to [ __ ] understand
this this does just not stop
at the leaders
because those leaders the tail is
wagging the dog here and it has been
wagging the dog for many many years
inside the gqp
they tried to appease to this white
supremacy movement they tried to appease
to these [ __ ] deplorables she was
right wasn't she wasn't she [ __ ]
right
you would think in our country
when there is a murderous dictator
bombing [ __ ] hospitals during a
ceasefire killing innocent civilians
the civilians rushing to to get out of
the country to get out of the way of
fire
all because vladimir putin doesn't like
democracy you would think in our
democracy
you would think that the people here
would have a little bit of [ __ ]
patriotism as they claimed to have
and they would step up to the plate
and they would put aside their [ __ ]
stupid ass q and on ideas and realize
that they've been [ __ ] duped
into believing russian propaganda
nope
can't do it
can't do it
but the tail
has been wagging the dog for a long time
and it is still wagging the dog on this
russian issue
and it will continue
pussyfooting around this eggshell
walking that they're doing
and it needs to stop
and the only way the only way that we
stop it is messaging we talked about
this yesterday with rachel bitkoffer
it is up to us
you think you think ron johnson and
tucker carlson are gonna do the right
thing
[ __ ] they're not gonna do the right
thing
never in a million years will those
[ __ ] be motivated to do the
right thing never
those pieces of [ __ ] trash
and anyone who is of their ilk that is
saying and propagating russian [ __ ]
as if to get
as if the gas prices are [ __ ] joe
biden's fault
and not the fact that we had to cut off
putin from the entire world and that
includes
strategically cutting off the oil listen
joe biden
is not making this decision because it's
a good political decision
joe biden isn't making sure to cut off
crude supply from russia which will
raise the price
naturally of gasoline because see
there's supply and demand
it does work that way now the president
united states is working in ways to try
to
increase that supply
so that we don't have that treacherous
gas prices
but he also has to fend off a murderous
dictator who wants to destroy
democracy
and generally speaking in this country
in america when we have someone who is
wants to destroy our [ __ ] democracy
we normally have two parties two parties
who stand against that [ __ ] enemy we
don't now we don't
we don't have two parties standing
against that [ __ ] enemy of democracy
we did 911 i'm old enough to [ __ ]
remember
i'm old enough to remember when this
[ __ ] country looked at each other and
said hey maybe we do have an enemy
somewhere that isn't here
right wrong or indifferent what happened
after 9 11 we did it as america
not as republicans not as democrats
we did it as america
again right wrong or indifferent we got
a lot wrong
and a lot to learn from 911
but the one thing we didn't learn
well that we unlearned
is how to come together
in a time of worldly need
vladimir putin is not just trying
vladimir putin is not trying to just
take over ukraine you dumb [ __ ]
he wants to destroy democracy his enemy
his enemy
is democracy
and the reason why it's his enemy is
because if his people the people in
russia see what democracy can deliver
them what they are lacking because of
real democracy is lacking there
he won't survive
in power
we the people of the most
are the enemy
of the totalitarian of the few
that's why they don't want democracy
that's why they don't like democracy
and mo is right here the enemy is within
now
and the reason why the enemy is within
is because
donald trump the cheeto dust mobster
grandpa poopy pants
when they supported him they supported
fascism
and it felt good oh man these
authoritarians really really [ __ ] got
their groove back
in this country
and they used all kinds of means
to get their groove back their
authoritarian dictorial ways
through the evangelical church
through the republican party
through the internet and facebook and q
anon
through absolute delusion on their
[ __ ] radio shows and their tv shows
fox news oan newsmax
they used a lot of
a lot of ends to meet their means
that means to meet their ends
and now we have a situation
where a certain portion of the
population it's a small percentage but
by god it's a large [ __ ] number it's
a large number of people
who think
that joe biden is the enemy of democracy
think about that for a second
there are millions of people in this
country
who have been brainwashed deluded
into authority authoritarianism so much
that they see any figure of authority as
an authoritarian
that's how much they believe in it
that's how much they long for it
they see every leader every one of them
as an authoritarian
not just not just trump
not just putin
i mean they love [ __ ] putin and they
love trump because they think they're
[ __ ] tough guys
little do they know they're the weakest
[ __ ] on the planet that's why
they do what they do that's why they lie
the way they lie that's why they deceive
the way they deceive
they're weak
joe biden may not be the greatest
speaker he may not be the almighty
president ever was and ever will be
but there's one thing for damn sure that
you cannot you cannot disagree with joe
biden
is he made a decision yesterday
to cut off our import from russia
despite his political position
it is not a good political position to
be in that the present united states
would intentionally
cut off a commodity
that our economy relies on
for the sake of democracy but he made
the right decision
and yes people in our country are going
to have to sacrifice a bid oh who'd have
thought sacrifice for democracy you know
you bunch of [ __ ] freedom truck
convoy having [ __ ]
out there thinking that you can just run
around not having to give anything for
democracy and democracy should be given
to you you entitled [ __ ]
you white country ass entitled
[ __ ] i know who you are
i know who the [ __ ] you are
you bunch of entitled [ __ ]
thinking that democracy should be given
to you that you can you don't have to
work for democracy it's just a thing
that's given to you it's not
democracy is [ __ ] hard that's why you
boneheads are [ __ ] so enamored by
authoritarianism because it's so easy
it's so easy for the god the golden calf
the leader to tell you what to do
think for your [ __ ] self
do your own research as you say
figure out a way figure out a way that
you can
help democracy and work for democracy
what do you think
what do you think jfk
meant when he said ask not
what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country
democracy is not [ __ ] easy
and every single fight every single inch
every single millimeter it's [ __ ]
worth it
to fight you [ __ ] fascist on the
don't say gay bill and this stupid
[ __ ] bill out of idaho and your
fascist [ __ ] anti-trans bill out of
texas to fight you on that it's worth
every god damn inch
for equality and equity for all no
matter who they are
no matter what they look like
no matter what gender what height what
what weight
what country they're from
rather they came here as a child or they
were born here
they're [ __ ] human beings
and humanity needs to be restored and we
cannot restore it with you [ __ ]
boneheads being diluted into
authoritarianism
so if you want your freedom
pluck your head out of your [ __ ] ass
and realize
that democracy
is hard
it's not given to you by one
[ __ ] it's not
joe biden doesn't grant us democracy
he doesn't he won't
he can he can help us defend it for damn
sure try not to work against it
try not to work against democracy
like the last [ __ ]
that you s you hold on high
so i'll challenge all the pro-democracy
people out there
make sure
as you're talking the audience out there
listening as you're as you're talking in
your community as people are saying
about gas prices
make sure they know the truth
the truth
and the truth is that joe biden doesn't
control gas prices
and the truth is the reason why gas
prices are going to be rising is because
of fascists around the world trying to
take over democracies that they're not
entitled to
regardless if that democracy is perfect
or not
you know there was a time in our country
where the republican party the president
of the united [ __ ] states of america
george w bush
was talking about spreading democracy
around the world
here we are less than [ __ ] 20 years
later about 20 years later
and they're doing the exact opposite
they want to crush democracy around the
world
give [ __ ]
excuses
for authoritarians and fascists
to destroy
democracies
and they want excuses to destroy them
here
that's what all these [ __ ]
that's what all these bigoted ass
fascist laws are about in these states
don't think they won't come after you
next
you're next
if they think they can get away with it
there's a [ __ ] bill in missouri
there's a bill in missouri that someone
is suggesting that that a woman would it
would be a felony for a woman to leave
the state to go get an abortion this is
supposed to be the party of states
rights
and then the state of missouri they're
suggesting a law that would make it
illegal for a [ __ ] citizen to leave
the state and go get a medical procedure
that is legal in another state
wrap your [ __ ] head around that [ __ ]
states rights my [ __ ] ass they never
were for states rights it was all the
ruse
they're [ __ ] fascist and they're
knocking on the door
they're knocking on the door and we
gotta we gotta fight back every inch
every single millimeter is worth it
don't forget that
so as you're out there talking make sure
you know
you know
who when those gas prices go up you know
who did that one biden who did that was
putin let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
to the shitless roundup where we round
up all the tweety tweets and the journey
trends of the day if you are just
joining us and you're new to the
audience here's what we do during the
shitless roundup which is sometimes the
majority of the show because there is so
much hit to round up on the list of
twitter we go through twitter we surf
twitter
every single well not every single day
we try every single day
sometimes we get sidetracked with great
interviews great guests
and some other things but we try to surf
the trendy trends in the tweety tweet so
if you are new to the show you're new to
listening
this is what we do during this part of
the show is we go through the tweet
tweets and the training trends just like
you do
every day on your phone during work
before you go to bed i know what you're
doing i see you people out there
tweeting before you go to bed i know
you're tweeting during work hours i know
you are
it's okay i'm guilty of the same thing
but we like to go through the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends here on the
tony michaels podcast
with the shitless roundup so let's get
to the timeline here um let's make this
a little bigger so you guys can you can
see and again if you're if you're
listening on the
the directories rather it's the the
directories that
that are that are boycotted or not
because we're on all the directories
we're on spotify apple google all of
them uh iheartradio wherever you find
your podcast we're on those directories
because we will not be silenced i don't
care who's boycotting what
platform we will not be silenced on any
of them
i believe we are going to yell and
scream as loud as we can always
but if you want to watch us if you want
to watch us surf the training trends and
tweet tweets you can do that too and you
don't have to do it live i mean we would
love to have you live in the chats and
the super chats we would love that
we would love to have you here
but you can subscribe to the youtube
channel
and that will get you the ability to
watch the show every day after the fact
we also post clips
if you want to just see certain parts of
the show
um we try to post clips every day of the
show are certain clips of the show but
if you want to watch us surf twitter and
see what we're reading and going through
follow and subscribe to the youtube
channel you can also find us on twitter
at tony michaels pod that's where the
show broadcast every single day is the
account at tony michael's pod follow us
there also we have the bonehead of the
week poll there don't miss that there's
gonna be some good boneheads this week
i'm sure
all right let's go straight to mayo i
see mayo in the chat here
mayo's here she gave us some fire
one of our favorites
she's a listener of the show and i'm a
fan of hers
can you believe that that is how this
show works
it it is amazing that i can sit here and
do a show and one of the people that i'm
a fan of
comes and listens to me it is fantastic
we love to have we love to have all of
you here and that's the other thing we
do is we get credit for all of you not
and for all of you new to the show here
we give credit for the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends that we read if we
read it we give credit
i'll show you how that works here mayo
says where should we ship
louise de joy
um i don't know to da jail maybe mayo
we do have to keep this account um for
mayo alive you guys know she's
she's been um she's been banned a couple
times but uh we love we love mayo here
mayo is one of my favorite one of the
show favorites
i know
i know you guys uh love mayo so give
mayo some love
go to her page give her some love here
in the chat we all love mayo
gabe has posted a video
of uh um
the snow lizard as i call him snow
lizard ted cruz
laugh out loud no one is hugging ted
cruz
no one
i mean do you remember the [ __ ] video
do you remember the video
when there it's like like when he was
running for president right
and his daughters are coming off the bus
and he's trying to kiss and hug them
like now get the [ __ ] away from me get
away from me
his his own daughters don't even want to
hug him there's no way this guy's
getting on a plane and somebody's
hugging him no [ __ ] way
no way i mean jesus christ his dog
snowflake probably doesn't even like
this [ __ ] and whose dog doesn't
like them
like who's dog doesn't like him and i'm
sure snowflake hates this son of a [ __ ]
let's listen to what this idiot has to
say every week yeah i fly back and forth
to houston
almost with i mean houston and cancun he
flies a lot to cancun i mean let's you
know maybe that's where he's getting his
hugs i don't know without exception
every time i'm on it i'm on an airplane
uh why is he so pissed about getting a
hug by the way
like he's really [ __ ] pissed off
about getting a hug isn't he like if you
were getting a lot of hugs without
exception every single [ __ ] airplane
you got on some stranger came up to you
said oh god i love you and gave you a
[ __ ] hug would you be really pissed
off about it
i mean he's [ __ ] pissed about he's
like [ __ ] i'm telling you
they're hugging me you don't believe
because it's not true no one's hugging
ted cruz
nobody
really honestly after covet is gone and
done away with and we get rid of the
mask we still should probably social
distance from ted cruz that's what we
probably should do that the captain or a
flight attendant will come up to me
will hug me and say thank you for
fighting for us because i'll tell you
united airlines sadly houston is a hub
of them
has fired thousands of pilots and flight
attendants
what difference does it make we're in
the district of columbia right now there
are mandates affecting kids in dc
this is
mandates oh god a private company is
issuing mandates can you imagine can you
imagine if i claim to be a free market
capitalist and i was advocating and i
was advocating for a private company
have private policies about their their
employees get the [ __ ] out of here with
this [ __ ]
come the [ __ ] on this has never been
your position ever in the history of
ever ever ted cruz get the [ __ ] over
yourself
pluck your head out of your ass and
realize what you're saying is a bunch of
[ __ ] number one no one is coming
even close enough to you to give you a
[ __ ] hug number one no [ __ ] hugs
for ted cruz no [ __ ] way no [ __ ]
how
number two number two quit being such a
[ __ ] hypocrite just take just get on
a flight go to cancun and stay there the
rest of america would be happy if you
did that let's give gabe some credit
here speaking of gabe
i think um
i think he's joining us now
uh gabe how are you this morning hey hey
what's going on i was just i was just
playing your tweet with ted cruz
um
yes getting hugs no one not even his
daughter would hug him and there's a
literal video proof right it's evidence
it's evidence i would like to uh you
know enter
exhibit a into
uh into evidence here which is uh oh are
you sending me a link no no that was
just
that was just me talking about how uh
how i see how his daughter is like that
that clip of her coming off the bus and
then right
like he's trying to hug and kiss her and
they're like no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no it's like super it's super cringe and
then what what what is that like b-roll
footage that they were shooting and they
and it ended up
probably
because they had like because remember
like super pacs can't like coordinate
with campaigns so what campaigns do a
lot of times is they shoot it would
either be just a b-roll or it would be
like news that were like oh with ted
cruz on the campaign oh so so maybe it
maybe it was uh
a journalist
right yeah and they're like you captured
a golden moment in time that will
forever be
uh just framed for the
no one ever wants to hug ted cruz that's
what it comes down to absolutely well so
you're but see i was even going a little
further earlier you're a dog owner you
have a guy you have two dogs and you
love your dogs right i do i love you and
they love you and even if you most of
the time well right but if you would be
frustrated with them
mad at them they're still gonna love you
right yeah there's an unconditional love
that's there right exactly because right
that that that love between a dog now a
cat's a completely different you know
yeah they're completely
dogs though are one thing
right do you i i have this sense i am
this belief that snowflake which is uh
in and of itself is a joke in and of
itself yeah right that that that ted
cruz's family's dog is named snowflake
but i i believe snowflake probably hates
this [ __ ] like oh
yes
right
right what wouldn't snuggle up next to
him on the couch no wait snowflakes
probably isn't even the same room as
this bastard exactly i mean
let let's look at the evidence here
right right one he lets uh
ted cruz he lets donald trump speak
uh
poorly of his wife calls her ugly right
well i mean i mean he openly supports
people and and ingratiates them
who calls his wife and yeah and cruz
said nothing right you know and he's
like uh
he's like i didn't say it wasn't not
true it's like okay dude
just right you didn't defend your wife
right two you uh you went to cancun when
a bunch of texans were freezing in their
home because the privatized group were
talking they were dying they were yeah
they're freezing and dying because uh
your state has a privatized grid and uh
thinks it's better than you know
connecting to everyone else in the event
that there is a disaster right but you
fly to cancun right because it's nice
and warm but then you get called out for
it and then you say well i was just
being a good father
and you blame it on your daughters right
then we find out that snowflake is left
alone just sitting there at the [ __ ]
door waiting
wondering
who's coming back
to feed me
and then the next point is how ted
cruz's own daughter
made a tick tock video that called him
out and said like this is what it's like
to live with my dad as a senator
and even said like we don't agree on
most anything like try i remember that
that that tick tock kind of going around
and i think uh when i tried to go search
it out because i wanted to see exactly
what was said make sure it wasn't like
doctored from her account or something
right i think her account is set to like
private on tick tock now you can't i
don't think you can see any of that um
but uh but no i i remember that tick
tock video and i think there were
several videos where she was criticizing
this the icon the snow lizard is what i
call him okay yeah yeah that works snow
lizard you know i mean he's he's i think
jimmy kimmel had it right uh
he is the blob right he's like this
[Laughter]
you know like i don't i you know that's
i've always i've always i've always
wished that he would like go to a
youtube video and figure out how a beard
works because the beard thing is just
not like he hasn't figured it out yet
he's got his whole like mullet wolverine
look yeah whatever the [ __ ] it is he
just the same guy who will show up in
basketball shorts and be like i was just
playing basketball i've seen the guy
play basketball it's not good like he
dribbled the ball hit himself in the
nuts he played against jimmy kimmel in
the
um
the
it's got the blob in the name but it was
something they were raising money for
charity and they were both they weren't
they both were not great at playing
basketball but holy [ __ ] ted cruz was
like really struggling he couldn't even
beat jimmy kimmel is what you're saying
no he did beat him he beat jimmy kimmel
yeah he did
i think it was good it's a strike
against jimmy really i know honestly i'd
like to ask him about that why he why he
remember
why he yeah absolutely yeah we'll
question him okay let's um
speaking of speaking of um
uh people losing uh you tweeted remember
proud boys leader
enrique tario was a prolific informant
for law enforcement for local and
federal law enforcement he will snitch i
mean cooperate to make a deal so you're
you're making assumptions here and i
think your assumptions are right
actually i mean i called it out once he
got uh arrested last year
right um
for
his charge against the church the black
lives matter flag
uh i was like this guy has a history
of being an informant with both of these
national like federal and state and
local as i said and i think
that uh speaking of
law enforcement i got one over are they
are they are they hear that can you get
that maybe maybe it's because we're
talking about him right now i'm live on
live all right they've gone by i'm safer
right now so basically enrique tario has
a history of this he was as and
literally quoted by his lawyers saying
that he was a prolific informant for
both local and federal law enforcement
in between the years of chosen 13 2014
something around there
yeah so helps with many operations to
take like actual people off the street
well so if if people aren't aware of um
the the abbreviated version of that
story and rigo enrique enrique is that
how you say how do you say his name
again enrique enrique tario okay enrique
i mean you could roll the r's but i
don't know how he actually said right it
should be right and it'd be like wish
i wish i was white maybe that's the
translation
i mean yes very much so anyways that the
abbreviated version of the story is is
that he was in big trouble with the feds
and the way that he got his prison
sentence reduced
is he was he became an informant for
federal law enforcement
to reduce his sentence because what you
would do during his sentencing is the
prosecutors would say hey they he helped
us with these other cases they would ask
the judge to reduce the federal
sentencing from the guidelines and the
judge the magistrate in that case would
do that and he did go to federal prison
he did go and he got leniency for the
for the informing that he did right um
it's not it probably is not easy to go
to a federal prison as a snitch but
everyone knew he was they knew he was
and coming out they knew he was and then
he entered into the proud boys mix and
they knew he was informed how they
didn't realize that he would remain an
informant i think the reason why the
reason why um
his public arrest yesterday is so
important because um they did it pretty
publicly like they made it very known
that he was being arrested um the law
enforcement can't always make sure that
press can't get pictures but they
definitely made sure that press got
they're like listen if you're going to
get a photo or a video make sure that
you stand about
right down
there right we're going to bring just be
southeast of where we're coming we're
going to walk down this and right bring
him back the other way right right we
may bring him around this way if you
happen to shoot a picture that might be
a thing you can do but
i think it's very important um yesterday
not only the fact that the feds indicted
him soon after the plea deal was uh
unsealed because that's the other thing
i think um people don't quite understand
about some of this federal stuff and a
lot of people you know they are waiting
for justice and we do need justice for
january 6.
but
a lot of these indictments may already
be sealed um they're waiting to unseal
them strategically and what that means
is they're looking for more cooperation
to keep going up the chain the most
important thing that i want to mention
about his case is that it is a
conspiracy case and that is the most
important thing about
um any case the other thing that's very
significant is he wasn't even there on
january 6. that is another very
important key to him being arrested it
being very public everyone know he's a
snitch
that snitch is being arrested i mean
this is very important this is very very
important that people understand that he
was not there he wasn't physically there
which we know other people who were i
don't know maybe at like the willard
hotel or in the white house
weren't physically in the capital
but they did have a hand in conspiracy
in planning it so i think that's very
important um so i appreciate your tweet
here i actually
i really did enjoyed this even though
you were trying to be comical it does
have a lot i mean i'm just being honest
you know well you know it happens it
happens
uh let's see
oh have you have you seen the mcdonald's
thing
um yeah yeah this is this is one of the
best one of the best don lewis here
he says people are saying mcdonald's
halting russian operations leaves trump
scrambling to change potential
relocation plans
do you think do you think if mcdonald's
does not exist in russia uh trump would
not would not flee there do you think he
would go somewhere else maybe yeah yeah
i mean if it's that important
yeah i i think uh i think trump would
definitely like i don't know what his
other eating habits are in terms of fast
food you know so he might be like oh
there's a chick-fil-a right or like
whatever uh whatever's fried and under
one of those red heat lamps i'm sure he
would love
right um
which is not too you know he's tanning
under a heat lamp he's eaten under a
heat lamp you know it's it's a lot of
heat lamp stuff going yeah a lot of red
orange heat lamps on him so right you
know birds of a feather
you know fries like another i don't know
whatever
um
but yeah i could see him definitely
being like oh well it's not available
there anymore i'm definitely going to
find a new spot and then you know goes
to another like oh north korea's got
mcdonald's right right
well you know that may be that may be a
landing spot for trump he you know the
other day and we didn't we haven't
talked about it much but but the other
day he was he was saying how much he
loves kim jong-un again and not only kim
jong-un but how kim jong-un's uh uh
staff treats him i mean you know it's
almost it's almost like they're scared
it's almost like they're scared kim
jong-un will murder them
yeah it's almost like there's a fear
that makes them all obedient
right and he's like i like i like how he
rules those people and like oh you you
like a dictator right you like a
tyrannical overlord right exactly
exactly well because that's the only
that's the only time he'll find the
obedience that he wants is by forcing
their hand to be like it's either life
or death and trump's like yep that's
exactly what i want yep that's right
that's right well and and he definitely
i think don is on to something here he
definitely would not go to russia if
there was a no fry zone uh yeah i think
that's the who who made that one is that
on the spot or did someone else make
that no i think i think um i don't know
who did that i think it might have been
aaron parnez um i read the tweet
yesterday oh you know what that is right
because he was like and i'm loving it
yeah that that's that's what it is yep
yep it's the no no no
a little jt in there yeah there you go
um wu-tang
is for children says remember the idiots
hoarding gas last year well they're the
same idiots crying about gas prices now
do you remember the idiots that hoarded
their gas last year and then i uh
[ __ ] torched their hummer to the
ground yeah i remember those people
did you see it is that is that the one
is that the one where they had the fuel
in the back and it caught yeah yeah and
it caught on fire and the whole thing
was just scorched yeah well you know it
let's just say that also i just want to
point out here in this photo these these
gallon jugs
are are are sideways right so
they're you know it's like hey listen if
there's ever a possibility that these
were going to leak in the car yeah well
uh it is you know at least 99 possible
now the other thing i want to point out
here is that it appears it appears in
this photo i can't prove this but all
these gas tanks look exactly the same
and they all appear to have the tags on
them and they all appear to be brand
spanking new oh yeah um so
not only did these people go hoard gas
at a time when
you know you you shouldn't toward gas
like this is the [ __ ] bone-headed
tree
that that is absolutely um baffling in
this country when something like like
what's happening now where joe biden
yesterday um cut off
uh russian uh import industry which is a
small small percentage right exactly it
will have an effect and they will we
will have to find another supply
but at the same time he is doing it not
of his own political gain he is actually
doing of the opposite right but these
people these people are doing having the
opposite reaction of what you're
supposed to have yeah like you're
supposed to say things like you know
what
it's going to be a [ __ ] paying a bit
more for gas maybe in the short term
because supply is gonna you know it's
gonna take a little bit of time to to
figure out what supply looks like
but in the short term it's worth it
because
we want democracy
and putin wants to destroy democracy all
around the world instead
these boneheads like these morons here
they fill up their you know their five
mile per gallon trucks and they drive
halfway across the country for their
freedom from mandates that don't exist
and then they make it into like a gas
price if you don't like it you know then
it's like well you know that's what
happens there's a bit of a wart like in
it
uh in
an inferred war tax that's put on
certain goods because
uh the global supply chain is shifted
because certain countries
might have exports that other countries
might need so it's like there's going to
be this tax that's put on to
certain commodities and also the other
thing the last thing i want to say about
this gas ball at least this example that
you showed was
gas doesn't sit well
for very long like it's not like you
have it in some sort of contains you
mean they actually have to make it and
it and it can go bad
yeah exactly it's like any other any
like you can have like oh i've got this
gas sitting in the fridge it's like okay
or in the fridge but in the
garage right in the fridge
i put gas in the fridge i keep it fresh
you know i don't want it to spoil
so
people who keep saying is that like is
that like when you make a gas cocktail
so it's cold yeah or yeah yeah it's
chilled you know so it goes it doesn't
burn as much when you drink you put this
in your show to stream the gasoline to
oh yeah bubble it up yeah level up
bubble up bubble up the gas baby oh all
our all right all right on gas all our
new viewers uh haven't haven't heard
maybe that gabe is an extreme
soda streamer i guess is that what you
call it um yeah it's it's an olympic
sport so it sounds like it sounds like
here that gabe is not huffing gas he's
drinking gas so i just want to point
that out
it's better that way when you drink it
it happens um
but yeah uh they're buying you know
containers worth of gasoline
and if they're you know if they're
driving that much that they're gonna go
through it that only means that they're
gonna go through it that quickly which
means they would go back to the gas
station to pay more because the gas
prices have gone up since then right um
but if you're buying containers full of
gas one not smart to house it in one
location like probably a garage that's
probably made of wood and
probably you know uh not good for the
conditions but the other thing is too is
like you just have gasoline sitting
somewhere right it's not gonna do well
like all these people who are like yeah
i bought a bunch of gas and it's like
okay well when do you how quickly you're
going to go through that gas and if you
don't go through it quickly enough it's
just going to sit in the garage it's
going to build up sediment it's going to
it's it you're not taking it straight
from the pump well the other the other
thing too is i don't think these morons
understand because they claim to be free
market capitalists they act like they
understand supply demand oh they love
econ oh
they are they are facebook ivermectin
institute economist aren't they
so here's here's what they don't get
about hoarding a particular commodity
that is um is has a supply problem when
they're when their [ __ ] is the price
like
if your [ __ ] is the price on the
commodity which is crude or gasoline as
it were the pro one product of crude
which is another thing they get mixed up
a barrels of crude oil equaling in the
gasoline crude oil isn't just equal
gasoline but you know that's a whole
nother that's a whole nother [ __ ] can
of worms that you would have to have
about 12 days to open with these
[ __ ] but here's the thing
they don't understand that when there is
a when there is a product like gasoline
and commodity like gasoline and you
hoard it because gas price is high
it actually reduces the supply at the
pump where you're buying it no so it
hurts
no
what you have to do is you have to
reduce your use of that commodity to try
to wait are you saying that
conservatives should conserve right
their use right you know it is it is a
very
very very uh
this is like fighting
this is like phd level type of like
right maybe concepts going on maybe we
should go to the ivermectin facebook
groups and and actually just drop the
definition of conservative or conserve i
don't think they'll get it but you know
it's neither here nor there they
actually have abandoned the definition
of conservative they've just abandoned
the dictionary all together well you
know they're like they tossed it they
tossed it in the fire when they burned
[ __ ] fahrenheit 451 and to kill
mockingbird right now well you know it
well and
maybe the dictionary it may have certain
words in it that offend them so they
can't have that dictionary about did you
maybe the dictionary just jumped in
itself it was like [ __ ] this i'm out
that's well
did you see did you see the other day
that dictionary.com retweeted a tweet of
mine speaking of dictionary i saw that
yeah so here's what happened and i'll
try to find the tweet um
well maybe we'll find maybe one
i tweet i was walking by my son's room
the other day and he said the one
website i trust with my life the most
is
dictionary.com
i was like what
i i didn't understand what it meant
but i thought it was tweetable like this
this phrase i trust the one website that
i trust with my life is dictionary.com
and i don't know if it's
you know
what the the kind of things that we're
talking about that he admires
dictionary.com but i did i did tweet it
and dictionary.com retweeted it so maybe
there's some validity in that and maybe
maybe they they can't burn
dictionary.com they can burn
dictionaries
the books but they can't burn
dictionary.com i guess there's
there's a theme between dictionary.com
and webster's they are
whoever runs their social media teams
deserves a raise because
uh that's not the first time that i've
seen them interact because there was the
um
who was the representative uh
last week god it feels like forever ago
i think it was last week yesterday
yesterday right
and aoc was like oh i've interact with
him in person and he talks like this
every day
who was that
i
you know
i really try to keep up with everything
but it is tony it is it is difficult in
today's age to have everything
that i can find hold on but it's not the
first time because webster's also came
in
and when
uh trump said wait no wait now wait is
dictionary.com and webster's are they
connected in some official way are you
no they're they're just literate that's
all
[Laughter]
so you mean they know words yeah they're
they're well they're well versed in the
words
you know they they know the best words
the best words right yeah do they use
the best words it's kind of what you're
saying
yeah i think they have a pretty good
handle on which words are the best words
to use uh you know i'm no expert but
they certainly are right right right but
but it seems to be the connection in
that they are very good at social media
that they uh seeing the social media a
lot of it is words right they have this
it was representative clay higgins i'm
sorry i'll send you a link right now
send me the link we'll pull it up here
um
yeah it's uh there's a there's a theme
from um
from like dictionary and webster's where
they have a they have
a a hilarious ability to just
correct you
or just correct whoever is saying that
dumb [ __ ] in the moment is pretty great
well let's let's uh let's pull this up
here and see what you're talking about
here
um
so this is clay higgins
and uh
apparently this guy is a a dumb ass uh
you millennial leftist
so he is a republican yeah this is oh
this is why woke sky was trending like
last week or whatever oh okay so so this
happens a lot too when they say
something really dumb
like lauren beaubert talking about
prince john right today prince john i
don't know who this is we'll talk prince
john from robin hood oh is it is that
what he's saying well he's actual prince
i mean prince john but it's referencing
prince john from [ __ ] robin hood is
that what she's is that what she's
saying okay well
let's get to that after this but
clay higgins says here you millennial
leftists who never lived one day under
nuclear threat can now reflect upon your
woke sky i don't know what that means
you made quite a non-binary fuse to save
the world from intercontinental
ballistic tweets
i i i know
that word salad is like their thing and
maybe this is code talk and usually i'm
on to the white dude code talk thing
i can't decipher this and it seems like
dictionary.com didn't either they said
um we're not entirely sure what this
tweet is supposed to mean
and we're literally the dictionary
so like they're admitting hey we know
these words we know what these words
mean we have no clue in the order that
you put them in what the context is or
what you're trying to [ __ ] say yeah
they are so far off the map of what
words mean yeah they're like listen we
tried we brought in literal experts to
break this tweet down to understand
exactly
what you meant
and
no one
linguists
people who can decipher
like no one could break this apart and
be like yeah it's crazy
but then look at the here's the
follow-up tweet there aoc sounds let me
get aoc up here
um let's see
so this is oh this is the the quote
tweet from him right okay so the same
tweet from clay higgins the the word
salad or what whatever i don't even know
if it's words it's like word slaw now
like it's not even word salad anymore
like they're dicing it up so small they
just threw it in the wood chipper and
that was like that's what came out right
right it's like it's a mad libs uh which
is a whole other idea
thank you actually thanks to thanks to
joe i was chatting with her about that
uh is making a mad libs for
just
just well republicans but also this may
be an idea that's coming then mm-hmm
yeah see i have folks out there i don't
know every single idea that's coming i i
i'm not abreast of all this stuff that's
why
a certain person shows up in wigs
sometimes or certain hats and i have no
[ __ ] idea who they're supposed to be
until until the screen is on uh aoc says
i've sat on a committee with this guy
for years
he talks like this every day he talks
like this every day so not only does
this guy uh apparently tweet word slaw
he talks word
he wasn't just like oh that was a weird
kind of jumble my phone did something
whatever it's like no he literally has
has
forms of words they're not actual senses
but they're formations of words that
come out of his mouth
and somewhere on a docket on the record
he has done this before so so what
you're saying is in official government
records clay higgins looks like a dumb
[ __ ]
yeah not surprising this is like not
someone who's like taking the notes like
shorthand notes and you'd be like what
does this even mean i'm not an expert on
shorthand notes like no that's literally
what he said this is this is as full as
i could make it right right right i even
added a couple commas down here it's to
make it somewhat understandable didn't
work yeah didn't work and and i i'm no
one to blame because a lot of my tweets
yeah let's face it i'm horrible i'm
horrible i'm [ __ ] horrible and as far
as word salad goes i've got a lot of
salad word salad to give let's be frank
but clay higgins you are a [ __ ]
bonehead okay um let's go back to the
trendy joins and the tweety tweets here
um
uh
one thing i wha what did we want to get
into wha what were we going to talk
about i said something
what was it
no no i we were i was going to say after
this we were going to talk about
something what did i say oh no you're
supposed to remember they're supposed to
write this they know i'm so sorry i
wasn't taking notes i was too involved
in this well uh so let's let's let's
talk about if you've got a few minutes
um talk about what is happening in
ukraine
um oh the prince john thing that's what
you want to go to let's go to ukraine
first because i definitely um in all
seriousness and the prince john thing
we're just gonna rake her through the
coals so let's let's do the ukraine
thing first it sounds like um
[Music]
there was a hospital that was bombed uh
during a ceasefire yeah um do you know
do you know the story behind this here
it is
i don't know the full story out there
are trying to establish the number of
casualties
um and access to wounded after the
russian air strike hit children's
hospital and meripol is that how you say
it
mayor you pull i don't know
mario paul i'm not sure how you say the
uh the town yeah yeah uh it's
m-a-r-i-u-p-o-l maybe dictionary.com
could help us um ukraine ap reports and
it's a children's hospitals what the
telegraph is reporting here breaking a
children's hospital has been destroyed
by russian airstrikes
in the besieged ukrainian city of mer
mario pool
mayor you open sorry here i'll i'll tell
you right now it is actually
mayor
mary opal
mary mary
okay mario paul women children and
medics were said to be trapped under the
rubble
following what was described as a direct
strike
on the building yeah um this is
intentional it seems um i mean it's a
war crime that's it it's well uh i i i
itarian law but i i will i will tell you
that um
the
the more days tick on here the less days
vladimir putin has left on this earth i
believe um this is getting to the point
to where it is gonna have to be done
with uh something with this so um
this is despicable and here's maybe some
video of it um i want to bring in
someone else maybe they've got an
opinion too we've got jordy myself here
hey jordy how are you what's up what's
up i'm all right i mean as right as i
can be well we are we are talking about
the uh the uh
airstrike on the children's hospital in
russia right now which is [ __ ]
despicable well it well uh honestly we
were talking about um
war crimes and i know you're probably
here to talk about maybe a legal af uh
episode that may be dropping today and i
don't know how much uh they're they're
looking at some of these walls that are
possibly being broken with these war
crimes um but
i'm not even privy to this footage we're
just recording or we're recording our
interview for the brother show not too
long ago so i've been out of pocket for
a minute now and then to come back and
see so now they've been targeting
children's hospitals today yeah so this
is a big tough russia is handling there
yep that's a big bad putin so this is
this is from um president zielinski's
twitter account um it's it says mario
paul direct strike of russian troops at
the maternity hospital people children
under the wreckage
atrocity how much longer will the world
be and accomplish ignoring terror
close the sky right now stop the
killings you have the power but you seem
to be losing humanity um i think he's
talking he's talking to us even
america that is
i don't know
what this footage has but i'm not going
to play the sound here but here is it
looks like a tour through what looks to
be the children's hospital that was
bombed now i believe um it's just this
big boy and just goes to show you how
desperate vladimir putin is right at the
first stand of it he thought he was
going to take ukraine in three hours
i think that things up right
right now that was his delusion right
yeah you know what what what happened is
he got propagandized by his own
propaganda propaganda he watched way too
much rt that he believed in himself
so he thought he was going to be this
big you know hero and
they go into ukraine obviously very much
unwelcomed because they are occupiers
and what they're doing there is
ridiculous and it's sad and it's a
travesty and this is the first war
that i can remember
that i think has ever played out on such
a live scale social media digital age if
you will yeah the videos coming out from
this at times they're incredibly heroic
right the ukrainian people you know
in the bot
it's honestly it's so sad you know
ukrainian people standing together even
even the more pro-democracy russian
folks over in russia who who still
protest the war um who aren't kowtowing
to putin um you know banding together
and and doing just that protesting the
war a crime that's honestly like
punishable by 25 30 years these days if
not death in russia
so
in darkness there is light but when you
see videos of children's hospitals
right being
targeted
yeah it's like oh you know who i think
i'm going to target i'm going to target
the people who can't defend themselves
like unbelievable it doesn't make any
sense outside of a guy who wants to who
is deranged delusional and you know is a
complete psychopath to say like i have
all the cards and i have all the power
and it's like well
you know whether that's true or not in
your mind like
i i think you're getting in something
there gabe with his delusion because um
i i think i think you're right jordy in
that
he has started to believe some of this
delusion that he's placed in this
propaganda that he's placed on his
people in his country and he started to
believe in his cause you know in 1930s
and 1940s nazi germany there was a point
where hitler
became not only a delusional uh leader
but a delusional commander in chief um
and his delusions were leading him in
ways that uh crippled his army um now i
i from what i understand
there is some advancement from russian
troops in parts of ukraine they have
been successful in taking parts of
ukraine and other parts they have not
been successful and this may be
a sign and i'm not sure exactly what
region this hospital is in but this may
be a sign of their desperation where
they're not making gains they're not
seeing the gains that they wanted
because russia the other delusion that
we've seen is russian equipment
is very insufficient their army and
their military is very insufficient i
mean the ukrainians as well prepared as
they were these are a lot of citizens i
mean i've seen videos of citizens like
marching
russian troops out of their town these
russian troops have weapons they got
pitchforks basically and they're like
get the [ __ ] out of here and they're and
they're basically shooing them out of
town um which is you know when you think
about it you know what kind of army is
the russian army
if they can be shoot out of town by
normal average citizens and their their
coats jackets and hats it's it it is a
sight
to see and it's disappointing that we
have to go through this and really
honestly the the reason why vladimir
putin is doing this is because democracy
is his enemy we talk about that here a
lot and i think that ultimately you know
everyone wants to say nato and all that
garbage tucker carlson talking about how
nato is the excuse or whatever the [ __ ]
he wants to say the point is is that
vladimir putin vladimir putin not only
hates democracy but he knows it's his
demise and the reason why it's his
demise is because if the russian people
are abreast to what democracy can
deliver them they know that putin will
not deliver them those things they will
not he will not deliver them liberty
jesus christ they banned the word war
in russia they banned the word war
forget that they've been going around
russian police officers if you will call
them that they've been going around on
the streets taking people's phones and
going through their text messages to see
what they've been talking about if
they've been talking about the war in
that way that is
and republicans in america are like oh
the tyrannical government of america
don't buy the socialist regime it's like
dude you could say what you want you can
say your dumb ass opinions all you want
on the internet and embarrass yourselves
but you do not see police walking down
the street and grabbing your phone and
looking to make sure that you're not
a dissident at all
against the of the the russian you know
the motherland well the funny part is is
all the people that are protesting with
freedom and you know all all this
nonsense they're the ones like yeah we
like putin's a tough guy that's who we
we would want a more putin-like leader
trump trump 2024
trump putin on the chicken
that's what we want we want a trump
putin ticket it just it doesn't mean
you're not even lying at all it doesn't
make any sense i wish it made sense
thank you thank you thank you mj for the
super chat there she says uh present i
was bogged down with work hi [ __ ] fan
minus mighty tony gabe and jordy so
thank you thank you mj for for the super
chat i will be curious to see uh uh what
they say today on the programs because
this is clearly it's like okay look you
guys just
you just [ __ ] hit a children's
hospital like no
no regard for human life no regard for
chill like what happened to save the
children right okay so i would love to
see what they say tonight because i'm
sure they're gonna scapegoat it blame
someone else say it's zielinski's fault
say it's nato's fault it's joe biden's
fault you know it's gonna be someone
else other than the dude who made the
order to send in and make an airstrike
against an uh hospital the people who
are there because they cannot they're
they're sick or injured or unwell and
they have nowhere else to go it's such a
weak week
week move oh yeah 100 percent i i i mean
i mean
they it sure looks it looks like they
were because they were they found uh
children under the rubble jesus adults
and
it's not going to be a good cowardice
move just now uh absolutely powered his
movement despicable every sense of the
word and that's what this guy is he's a
lunatic he's an absolutely
batshit crazy lunatic that needs to be
stopped these sanctions are going to
work the sanctions are going to work
only up until a certain point though
right right so we here are all going to
have to figure out
when is enough enough right and when is
it the right time to actually put some
boots on the ground and figure out the
situation and before things get worse
and that is a good point because i think
the hesitation of the the biden
administration and even western
democracy in general is that putin does
have a finger on a nuclear weapon and
the worst possible situation here is
that he would he would launch some kind
of nuclear attack uh into ukraine or
another country uh which would be
completely devastating i don't even
wouldn't pet it past him using those
sorts of weapons on his own people at
this
doesn't care for his point
people he doesn't care about his own
people at all he only cares about the
oligarchs honestly well i mean the
people the people are pawns and there
are means to an end and is willing to
sacrifice their lives if it means he's
able to stay in power and keep himself
as well as the oligarchs
just because he doesn't care he doesn't
care that the economy is in literal
shambles that rubles are trading at less
than a penny that only affects
residents of russia right that doesn't
really affect his oligarchs yes maybe
maybe it does to a certain degree but
come on don't be naive they have money
stashed away all over the world right
there will be there's still time
yeah they'll still be just fine and it's
a great correlation if you will great
probably not the right choice awards but
it's a great strong correlation between
how putin
treats his residents the people living
in russia and the army right he sent
thousands now thousands and thousands of
troops into ukraine
no regard for their lives
and some of them obviously have come
back and they're like i didn't know what
i was here to do like i was told i was
doing one thing and then you gave me a
you told me i had to shoot these people
and i didn't want to do it right like
these are you know like again it's the
same thing if people are like oh we
should blame all russians it's like a
little hold up no don't do not place
blame on all the russians right right
like you're close to that trap don't get
right right right place blame on putin
his whole team that is the one executing
this and obviously the ones within the
military who are like maliciously going
out to kill innocent people
um you know
that's a good point that's a good point
too as to where the blame goes because a
lot of the blame in the next few months
um for any problem here in this country
obviously the right is going to blame
joe biden um but a lot of our strife
especially economically here um if it
has to do with pump prices is it is
vladimir putin's fault he did do that he
did it to the western world he did it to
the whole world by having his little um
fascist little uh entry into ukraine
here so everyone needs to make sure that
the pro-democracy messaging out there is
that it this is putin's fault he did
this not only to himself he did it to
his people and he's doing it to us
because we have to deal with this
situation we cannot let this murderous
[ __ ] dictator bomb and kill innocent
women and children bombing children's
hospitals for crying out loud it's
ridiculous jordy i know you came on and
uh um i know when you came in it was a
touchy subject here but yeah i think you
came on like i'm gonna shoot the [ __ ]
with guys yeah you're right right we can
still shoot this we can shoot this [ __ ]
man
we can switch gears on the show that's
what we're doing right now i was just
watching up to when i'm new i'm like
okay now i'm going to come on now
before right right right you definitely
you definitely don't want to break in
maybe on such a serious time but we
appreciate your commentary because i
know you've been paying attention to
this stuff over in ukraine but outside
of that you did want to come on to talk
about something that's happening today
possibly with the nice meeting tonight
tonight tonight tonight uh wednesday
night we do our wednesday edition of our
legal af podcast this one is hosted by
the magnificent
kfa and michael popock so we like to
split them up kfa's just a renowned
lawyer she's actually psy vance's number
two so she's able to give uh these law
breakdowns from someone in the know
which is i know there's some things she
can't say though something she
something's right she'll notice like she
knows she knows but she cannot something
but she will say and give up all the
information that she's allowed to right
so she does an awesome job uh and of
course i think everyone here knows um
michael popock popakians shout out
popakians so they do a wednesday edition
it's much shorter it's about 25 30
minutes 35 minutes and they basically go
through just the legal craziness of the
weeks
so definitely tune in tonight that
show's going to go live at 8 pm eastern
uh get that wherever
you
get your podcast or watch your podcast
be it youtube facebook twitter wherever
um this week it will broadcast last week
i know there was a little bit of an
issue because yeah yeah hold on let me
let me get down my spiel and then we
could get back to that okay and then
definitely download it on the podcast
app wherever you get your podcast leave
a five star review that would be amazing
and then of course we do another legal
af uh on saturday sunday um so make sure
you check out those as well big bro
big bro on that that's the one that ben
and michael popock do uh together i
think last time there were 1500 people
watching all at once it was really
incredible and i mean there's never a
dull legal week
there's always a [ __ ] showing you're
like what
and honestly i could say this because
ben's not here right now so i'm allowed
to give him props and he's not around me
the way they really break down the
craziness in the law i mean if i can
understand it i like to say everybody
should be able to understand yeah right
and they do it in such a way where
they're not talking at you we're not
talking down to you but really just
explaining like the legalities of what
these terms mean and just
you know the nuances of the situation
that you may
already think you know but could have a
walking away having a much better
understanding of what you just listened
to yeah but don't don't tell brett this
because i know you you help
it's a good thing because brett doesn't
watch this right you
you help you you you help produce legal
af you're very involved in a production
league very involved very involved but
but i will have to say uh we do have uh
salty for those out there adam salton
man this kid is a superstar he's a
senior in college right now i'm hoping
i'm not giving away too much information
about him uh we're we're hoping to lock
him down full-time he's the one that
gets in the weeds and starts editing
those shows um all i pretty much do is i
hit record uh
influence is here and there and the
reason why i was going there is because
i i don't want brett to you know feel
left out but legal af is one of my
favorite
podcasts and it's it it it is because of
the breakdown like you were talking
about it is easy to understand the other
nice part that i really like about it is
they really take that week right and
then wednesday show does it well the
saturday show does it well and they
really pack in like what you need to
know from last week so next week you're
caught up it's like you go to
exactly and that's what i love so much
about too it's like a class it's like
you're taking an online law class right
um and staying abreast of those currency
yeah while blessed everything that's
happening currently and everyone's
learning in real time i mean the coolest
feature of this stuff is the podcast is
stuff
those elements are great but there's a
chat function on the youtube um where
all of the different midas mighty legal
afers popakians were all talking you
know sort of about the law about the
situation that they're talking about oh
they're talking about it right now look
minus robin says she loves legal af yes
there we go i will say that is
the minus that is the great thing about
the show is that like if you were to
think about class right class you work
in either past events or hypotheticals
right right and you're like well let's
think about this potential case study
here uh or it's something that's like
years ago and you're like would that
ever happen today i don't know but now
you're able to say like okay this thing
happened two days ago let's break this
[ __ ] down and here's what's here's
what's going to happen yeah and they
give their insights like heroes yeah
here are the possible options that they
could play forward what would be the
result of each of them and then you're
like okay within three days we'll come
back and assess up turns out they chose
door a right or door
and that was the one they went to and
this is now the result right like
there's like this decision tree of
potential events decision tree do you
hear this jordy i like that
yeah you should you should start yeah i
went to dictionary.com this morning
all about the words just all the words
you know i i appreciate you joining us
jordy you probably do you have to bounce
yeah i guess so i guess no you can't say
hey you can say if you want you can see
no no i know i'll take i'll take care of
a few things in the background but it's
such a pleasure as always thank god so
much for having me on me
tell us tell us again what time what
time does it does tonight's legal af
goes live at 8pm eastern uh that's
wherever you get your podcast uh make
sure you watch it come join the youtube
watch party that's my favorite if you're
on facebook we're not gonna platform
shame here enjoy it it's gonna be great
love y'all people on facebook might need
it the most just
there you're right are you going to give
a shout out are you going to give it we
we got to have the jordy shout out give
us the geordie show oh wow can i yeah
you absolutely
it's your show i didn't want to no go
ahead go ahead we want you to give the
shout out shout out to the midas my day
thank you thank you jordy for joining us
thanks man we'll talk to you soon buddy
we'll see you hey and by the way you
guys are doing such a great job i love
the show we appreciate it we appreciate
you keep it up and keep keep on bringing
it because oh we're we're going to keep
the pro democracy message out there we
promise man thanks jordy for joining us
everyone check out legal af tonight um
wherever you get your your podcast um
let's go back to the uh
to the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends here
yeah uh how much time do you got left uh
over there i'll kick it again man oh
you're are you in it to win it i'm in it
to win it in it to win it okay well um
you win it so i i hate that uh that he
had to come in on the uh the children's
hospital thing but i think he had some i
think he had some good insight i know
jordy's been following this ukraine
stuff because they have been over on
their show um the midas touch podcast uh
trying to talk about it a lot and
following yeah because now yeah we're
like what i think it's uh
two two weeks
it it's um i think it's yeah i think
we're up to 14 days something like that
um that this conflict has been going on
um
we see here in the trends um
we've got gop lies about everything now
um biden gas crisis uh jesus uh biden
answered the three i don't know what
that means oh it's uh there's a and i i
think it's an op-ed or it's a story but
it's about how biden answered the 3 a.m
call right so there's a hypo it starts
out i wasn't i wasn't able to finish the
the article before coming on the show
but it talks about like you know hillary
clinton made an ad i think during the
2016 game campaign and was like when you
know
uh you're home asleep and you're with
your family you know all like tucked in
and you know there's a crisis and a call
comes in at 3 a.m who do you want to be
the person that takes a call and they're
saying that biden in this conflict was
that person that took the 3am call i
will also point out my little like
asterisk on there is that uh trump is
the guy
[ __ ] at 3 a.m
now yesterday yesterday you talked about
sending tweets on the uh on the show yes
and i do say that there's another person
that i remember who took uh who made you
send tweets uh while on the on the
[ __ ] as well and that was donald
trump however those are rage tweets
right well he's like really pushing it
out you know he's like well i mean to be
fair some of my tweets could be
considered rage tweets well yeah i mean
it depends on like what part of the
movement you're in you know right
exactly exactly but but i will i will i
will say that um speaking from
experience tweeting from the commode
isn't always the best option but
sometimes it depends on what you had the
night before or lunch it is the only it
is the only option so big risk just
throwing a reward right right i'm just
throwing that out there yeah just
throwing that up
oh i we played the clip on twitter i and
and i actually i didn't know if you
would allow me to collab with you on
yeah i accept it i'll tell you i didn't
have to i didn't i didn't have much to
say but i wanted people to catch what
their reaction about their reaction was
the best part your reaction i think is
the best part of the entire video
when you're like you [ __ ] crazy son
of a [ __ ]
it's like you know listen i do most of
my research right on the [ __ ] oh okay
so you're actually you're not actually
putting out content you're trying to
research for it yeah me and those
trumpers uh we're like a venn diagram
it's like you know where we do our
research and it's on the [ __ ] right
okay i got you i got you so so that meme
where you're where you do your own
research yeah that's that's that's yeah
yeah okay well i'm where i'm coming up
my arm chair
uh doctor opinions right and legal
opinions the thing i have to ask though
the thing i have to ask though is during
your research do you get so caught up in
your research that like my legs fall
asleep you're leaving softy you knew
exactly where i was going to go with
this because it happens doesn't it yeah
yeah yeah and then i'm like uh what the
hell is this witchcraft you know because
i don't believe in science either so
you know it's like why are my legs
falling asleep it's it's got to be
biden's fault and i was like i didn't
put a hex on my legs you know jumping
i didn't do that and it's not that they
fell asleep because i was cutting off
circulation but it's because jibadan did
it it's probably that vaccine too it is
it's working its way down slowly because
gravity you know right that's what they
say i don't believe in science but they
say that right it might be it might be
that you're being digitized too yeah i
don't know yes okay so
so let's go to prince john here uh
this headline really is giving her a lot
of credit here colorado representative
lauren bobert that is a
i i don't know if colorado would agree
that she's a very good representative
but you know whatever it seems like
they're giving her
a lot of
credit there i don't know who's running
the federal government these days joe
biden or prince john during a fox news
appearance um this is where the prince
john enters the chat there's got to be a
video of it here
yeah yeah somewhere oh there we are
lucky there oh um here it is here it is
apparently she's on uh jessie waters
show that nitwit um it's not surprising
that she's on his shoe whose book got a
review from trump that was stolen from
amazon classic
oh yeah who jesse waters yeah cause
jesse waters he had a yeah that was a
he had a he it was a coloring book a
color no no it was a book with words
many some words were made from the
dictionary right uh but he had a book
and trump uh sent out a press release
like his little announcement thing okay
because he can't tweet right right
exactly and it was his like um
uh like recommendation review kind of
like seal of approval right
only to find out
that
it was uh copied verbatim from the
amazon review from like the editor
wait a second wait a second so
he goes he do you think he went to
amazon or do you think someone's like
because here's i i
was like here's an example of what you
would say exactly like and he goes okay
yep and he just tweet he just copied
exactly yeah he just he just retyped it
out no one will ever know yeah no no no
one re amazon jeff bezos i hate jeff
bezos because he does
and uh well he's jealous he's jelly of
just right exactly i mean
i mean he's it's not like a hatred like
you know there's something justified
he's really jealous that jeff bezos is
actually the person that he would love
exactly
yeah so that's what's happening man i
got this goddamn lawnmower next to me
again no huh i can't hear it i don't
know if i talk
it's probably those people with all
those gas cans they're probably running
the lawn mower it's like come on man
well i mean it takes a lot of gas to
learn a lot more let's apologize for
anyone listening let's listen to what
bobo the clown had to say on jesse
waters show work not opec and i don't
know who's running the federal
government these days uh joe biden or
john uh from uh uh
uh prince john but they're taxing us
into poverty look okay
uh joe
prince john from uh
like what i i actually didn't know what
the prince john reference was i this is
the first time i watched this tweet are
this disclaimer i mean there was a real
prince john
right but that's not the prince john
she's referring to right okay so so so
tell the audience tell the audience what
she's what she thinks she's trying to
say she's trying to she's trying to use
a comparison she's not saying what she's
she's trying to make a comparison of
like robin hood so it makes it seem like
so she's saying that
uh
i think by comparison she's saying that
the republican party is robin hood and
that joe biden
is prince john so if you remember prince
john he was like he was the lion right
right right right well yeah so if you if
you go back to the disney version of
robin hood he's the he's the lion king
right right okay he's the villain in the
story right and so i think by comparison
she's
almost trying to make it seem like
republicans are robin hood in this
situation which is hilarious because
they are the complete opposite right
right right and and the people who want
to tax others into poverty are the
republican party
so
you know they they don't want to pay
taxes but they want to tax others you
know right exactly well but outspoken
here says prince john is taxing us into
poverty that's the quote
but here's the thing
is gas prices going up is not a it's not
a tax see
um that's
for there's
a there is a small tax a a nominal
sense like i don't know well it depends
on the state too like like right right
but i mean the people that are deciding
i mean like there is a federal tax on
gas right exactly right it is like sense
it is like
in the teens of sense right but when
they're like oh joe biden the federal
government is like no actually
actually for whatever reason it's not
illegal these gas stations are the ones
that are price gouging you these
companies are deciding what the prices
are well it's opec too i mean no exactly
i mean like obviously from the oil side
it's opec then you've got the actual
gasoline with the people who have
refined the oil into gasoline and sell
it back to you to pump in your car those
places say oh we're going to determine
what the gas price is like for instance
in my neighborhood i've got a gas
station down the road and i've got one
up on the road and then one down and the
one up straight up this way is the most
expensive in the neighborhood now you go
two they have the best hot dogs do they
have the best hot dogs i'm just saying
i'm trying to figure out why no they
don't have any it's the same it's the
same thing you know why are they more
expensive gabe there has to be a reason
it's just because they can
maybe the neighborhood you know but ever
then you go two blocks down the street
and you see that that one is the
cheapest one in the neighborhood that's
i think a shell so they probably have
like the dirtiest restrooms then there's
gotta be a reason here there's no reason
man i'm telling
they just want it to be whatever they
want and so they determine the price
right now
and you'll see that in a neighborhood
we'll be like oh here are two competing
places i'm gonna undercut
the uh the the gas station across the
street
but then i'm gonna jack up the price on
one over here like if i in la like it's
all it's you know between the
neighborhood i live in and there's like
downtown l.a and there's beverly hills
like the prices are fluctuating
as a total in the county an area but
they even fluctuate within different
neighborhoods because of you know
because they can't it's not like oh i'm
going to set them all equal
and make it available
and say great the price is
three dollars no i'm gonna be like it's
four over there it's five over here it's
three over here
and it's you know like they determine
how they want a price gouge and it's not
illegal which is crazy
i still i still say i still say there
must be something about the bathroom the
hot dogs i'm just saying um christina
sent this she says awesome as always i
think perhaps
representative bobert was referring to
this prince john exactly um i the text
is i remember the i remember this is
actually a really good disney movie and
you got that snake there you know it
it's just like
that is the republican party
but to say that joe biden jubilant
is uh prince john
is uh
it's a little stretch yeah it's a
stretch it's a because by again by
comparison they're making themselves
like he's the villain and republicans
are the savior which means they're robin
hood no
no they're not they're the ones who are
taking money out of your pocket they're
the ones who don't want to give you a
child tax credit they're the ones who
you know like you go down the list of
things they're the ones who are who are
taking away your right to even say the
word gay they're the ones who are taking
away your right as a you know they're
the king they're the tyrannical right
they are the people who are trying to
control what you say despite the fact
they're like oh no we're the party of
free speech and we're the party of the
you know you know the first and the
second amendment they can't say anything
else in terms of amendments uh they're
the ones who want to control how you
feel
how you live what you do
and then the reverse if you ever speak
out against it they go oh look at these
guys they're trying to cancel us for for
speaking our truth and it's like well
your truth is a little bit dick like a
dictator and tyrannical so well here in
here in uh uh classic fashion because
they're gonna attack this too you know
they're gonna say what you're saying
about this executive order right because
they're going to say oh he's he's
committing tyranny
by um signing an executive order here's
the headline ap has it
biden signs executive already on
cryptocurrency oversight urging the
federal reserve to explore whether it
should create its own digital currency
um he directs treasury and other
agencies to study crypto's impact on
financial stability and national
security now what they're gonna do what
they're gonna do here is say oh look at
the tyrannical dictator trying to trying
to knock down crypto that's not what
he's doing he's trying to make sure
that these crypto markets don't take
advantage of normal average working
people and steal their life savings
right like that's what he's trying to
make sure that they don't steal what
from you what is yours
by by not being regulated by not
exploring the option of making sure that
the federal government does everything
they can to protect their citizens from
what may be a scam right and i can't
tell you how many times like i
i was mining bitcoin back in 2012 2013
uh and
when my co-worker was like hey let's you
know buy a butterfly miner and so we
kind of hooked up a computer and just
kind of like let it run you're speaking
foreign language but okay keep going
yeah yeah basically instead of buying
bitcoin we had a miner
that was doing it for us right so it was
mining it was you know contributing back
to the pool and you know
anyway basically creating creating the
bitcoin yeah we're mining away and being
like great we're able to solve these
mathematical problems and you know we uh
we earn we earn for contributing to the
power right because also bitcoin like
crypto is is an environmental tax
because in the sense of like your
uh more electricity
uh
power heat like these are things that
are used to to keep these things running
because it takes so much
machine like energy um is the the
simplest way i can put it
now
um
i cannot tell you how many times i've
seen people scammed
uh a in exchange that was opened
like like hey come to the website put
your money in like you can exchange you
can sell this that and the person who
owned it was under investigation they
shut it down and stole everyone's money
right like these are people who have the
admin super admin access
who are not in any way regulated and
they're using these sites that are
either hosted in other countries or or
done within the us and then something
goes awry and that person is
investigated for
some sort of fraud or some sort of
illegal activity and that person goes
i'm about to bounce and i'm stealing
everybody's money with me and then or it
gets hacked or whatever it is i can't
again i can't tell you how many times
i've seen it over the last
you know nearly 10 years i've i've been
uh involved in crypto in some way shape
or form uh how many times people have
been scammed or stolen or hacked or what
have you and there was even a case most
recently where a couple
was part of this uh uh scam they stole
money yeah yeah yeah i've seen it um
and they caught they were making like a
bunch of social media videos and stuff
yeah and they're posting so it's you
know it's like oh yeah hey we want to
democratize and deregulate crypto
i get it i get it you okay totally
because it does
it does have benefits however uh you
know with all things there should be
some regulation to make sure that it's
uh
uh uh uh uh that it that it there is
some protection in place
um
so
well and and i think that's that's the
aim here is to make sure to protect um
normal citizens average citizens savings
right like because that's a lot of times
like what you're saying you were
creating bitcoin a lot of people are
putting their money in and this thing
fluctuates up and down so much it is
very it is very much a volatile market
right and
someone someone could put a lot of their
life savings and think they're gonna
make a lot of money they lose it all and
they sell at the wrong time which makes
them lose all their life savings and i
think that is what is that is what um
the president of the united states and
the federal reserve should
have an interest of the citizens is that
hey
we want to make sure that where crypto
is a scam that people know it's a scam
because i'm not i'm not so sure and
we're actually going to have a guest
that we're going to interview on friday
um that i want to ask a bunch of these
questions to you because i am very
interested because i don't know a lot
about it and i know you probably know
more than i know because it sounds like
you've you've done this stuff before so
this guest on friday we're going to have
um that we're going to interview on
friday hopefully we'll air it next week
um is is we're going to ask a lot of
these questions too um because
he's actually selling crypto right like
he's right well he's selling advocating
for right right yeah
the the
the other thing too is like there are
obviously the the staples that everyone
knows right there's litecoin and there's
ethereum and there's bitcoin um you know
everyone's like you know there was the
whole thing with uh
with elon musk where he's like dogecoin
right dogecoin
started off as a joke right just the
same way that you had like yet coin
which is kanye coin these these coins
started back in 2013 or so
now what what do you mean as a joke
because i i think that's important for
people understand is that is you're
saying to create these things they
create these so yeah you make these
coins public right and you've got uh
dogecoin which if anyone doesn't know do
like doge is the shibuyinu um they're
like oh such wow oh amazing like you've
seen those memes right right uh that's
what that coin is based like that it's
it's a joke it's based on a joke it's
based on a joke and people inflated
value to it and that's what that whole
thing last year was right there was the
whole thing with robin hood
and not to be confused with the last
robin hood right right but robin hood
the app but ironically enough robin hood
this uh trading this app uh where you
can trade stocks but also crypto um
got involved and stopped the ability to
sell
right uh and only allowed you know you
had vcs who are able to uh to make
things and then you had
um
and uh the thing is
at the same time you know carter over
here makes a good point which is like
you know don't just create never have a
limit right so bitcoin does have a limit
which means that you know the
you're you're you're going into infinity
what the the coins that are that are
mined are created for dogecoin are
infinite right see you
theoretically it doesn't have to stop it
doesn't stop right bitcoin is finite
right you're going to get to a point
where you run out and you cannot mine
anymore and that it is what it is what
it is yeah exactly and so there are the
staples but then you got these other
ones that people make almost every day
you know kind of uh that are that are
either a scam or a joke and then it's
all based on how people are are valuing
those things they put that right to them
but it's not that they actually
hold value is this the same thing
because
another thing that we're going to talk
to this guest about i'm sure that'll
come up is the nft thing right
because i don't think there was anything
in this executive order about nfts b but
it's kind of it's not the same thing but
it's this
it's kind of this imaginary investment
thing right it's not a tangible thing
right so nfts are they're trying to
place value on it like so let's say that
i buy a piece of artwork off a wall from
someone right that's a physical piece
that no one else has that's the right
one
you can bring it and hang it on your
wall yeah exactly people can make copies
or or impressions of those you know or
like recreate them but you will be the
only one with that original van gogh
let's say right now for an nft let's say
i make some sort of digital uh artwork
right
the idea there is that i'm selling the
original like you have you are the only
actual owner of this
do i believe in nft
uh no i don't i mean in the sense of
like i don't know and i'm happy to talk
with you and you're a designer you're a
designer too right right and i like yeah
sure i would love to sell a piece of
artwork for like 20 million dollars
however this is why i also have an issue
as an artist i have a real big issue
with how art is valued within the
industry and the community uh and how
people
place a price tag on uh artificially
right it's the same thing of like oh
well this artist had this intent when
they were making this and it's like i
could be the artist in the room be like
no i was [ __ ] high and i
didn't it doesn't actually mean well
right but but but isn't there isn't
there actually a valid argument to say
that the reason why some of this art is
valued so high is so that people can
transfer wealth i mean it's not really
like you know it's you're you know
you're you're making the original
artworks you're like oh i made the
original that's mine like i own the copy
right right but at the same time it's
like it doesn't stop like the actual art
the actual aspect of tracking someone
down to be like oh i was able to do
you know take a screenshot you know
clean it up do this and then claim it's
mine or make a modification or whatever
like that's the other thing too there's
nfts i don't have a lot of faith in
because i feel like it's uh but the nft
thing feels like the new crypto thing
like well i mean it's like tied together
that's where it's like right you know
you're getting it's all digital right
right you're making a digital currency
around this so you sell these things and
i i just don't
me again i'm an artist and i have stuff
and yeah i would love to sell this stuff
online but at the same time it's like
it doesn't stop anyone from stealing
right and like if you have you can
screenshot anything right if you look at
i have friends i have friends who who
make uh
you know actual paintings and sells
prints online right they're they're
painting like a canvas as well right
yeah and then he will have those prints
digitized
and put online so you could buy actual
just like prints of it right right um
i've had
uh
i've had him send me um
uh stores
like stores in china
that have taken
and selling it so the thing is like when
things become digital it is very easy to
counterfeit them
and so
that's what carter sketcher carter's
saying here is is very right exactly
digital i mean i mean i i i i don't i
don't mean to um i don't mean to say
that that um
that i'm trying to copy or copy or
counterfeit but i screenshot a lot of
stuff right i mean i know a lot of
people probably see a meme they like
like i'm gonna screenshot that or
whatever you know like uh
and you keep it in your quote-unquote
library and you know you you uh
you you counterfeit them as as it were
it is i mean like there was an artist uh
you know the last thing i'll say about
this too is there was an artist that i
for
i think maybe new york he was taking
people's uh instagram photos right and
he was putting and if i can find it i'll
send it over to you but he was taking
people's instagram photos and he was
printing them out and putting them on a
wall in a gallery and was selling that
so he didn't do anything this was other
people's content
he was just taking the best pictures
they had and printing them out exactly
it wasn't no no it was like he went to
instagram and he the the image that was
there was like the profile photo the
username the photo and then like how
many likes in the comments underneath
and it was just that there wasn't so it
isn't instagram is what he was playing
it is a yes it is a a photo not just the
image but yeah it's the it's the
interaction with the instagram on it
like how many likes and comments and
stuff like that
and that guy was selling this artwork
and there's a whole thing about like
whether he's actually an artist you know
and again it comes back to this whole
like art community thing was like what
is actual art right not art you know is
it your art to sell you know like you
put it out online does that make it open
for anyone to take and do you know the
same thing about yeah
well there's a good here's a good
example so i just went to my tic tac
i've been posting more videos on dick
duck and i decided because this was not
my policy before i turned off the
ability for people to download my videos
on tick tock i did that yeah and it's
because i felt like well it's my video
it's mine i mean you can rip it if you
want like rip it off i don't care screen
screen grab it if you want but it's mine
i don't want you to download now i
recently changed that i changed my mind
um for whatever reason you know it's not
worth the the hour-long discussion i'm
sure i'd have here but but i did
recently go to tick tock and turn on
where you can download those videos and
the reason why is here in an abbreviated
form is i was posting other videos that
i was finding on my tick tock so i was i
was taking videos that i found postings
for people to see so i said you know i
can't i can't now it's not all my
content right right so now what i have
to do is i have to now let people
download my content because i'm posting
content on my page that is not mine i'm
just posting it for people to see right
i just want you to see it and so that's
a good policy right like you're you know
you're you're taking from the community
and allowing the community to take right
exactly so that's that's why it kind of
again it's abbreviated but that was the
reason why
i've made a ton of memes and that's why
you know that's why i've started like
adding my handle on there not that
anyone couldn't crop it out or do
whatever to it right at least it's an
attempt to say like i take ownership of
this you have credit right but again
it's the internet and someone's gonna
steal it it's nice to be like oh look
i've my meme is out there like right
being shared around right right and
you're not getting paid for it it's
right i'm not i'm just making it because
it makes me you know it gives me a laugh
and other people uh laughed as well now
again like i said somebody could
could uh
could take it and they could do whatever
they want with it uh but at least i'm
trying to be like oh i was the original
creator whether or not that actually
means anything these days but
so before we move on to the last story
here because i want to get to it it
looks like it's breaking news um i do
want to say about art and creating art
is that's what we try to do here on the
show and it it is it is something that
we provide um and we try to give you the
content that we provide and again we
have the super chat which is a cr a
crazy cool way of contributing to the
show so if you guys like the art that we
make here because me and gabe feel like
this is the art the expression that we
make um we do it every single day two
hours a day noon eastern eleven century
youtube twitter twitch so if you like we
do have the super chat now you can uh
you can contribute that way or you can
go to the tonymichaels.com and both of
our merch stores if you'd like some art
that you would own some tangible art
that you'd own yourself you can go there
and look at the [ __ ] hats gabe has
a red hat shirts um he's got bobo clown
shirts speaking of a clown
and uh colorado um we have breaking news
uh npr reports uh mesa county colorado
let me get my zoom right here colorado
clerk tina peters and her deputy have
been indicted by a grand jury on 13
total accounts related to election
tampering and misconduct now wait a
second what parties
is she which party is she in i'm sure
she has to be a democrat right right
gabe she has to be because only
democrats cheat to win i've been told
that democrats are cheaters
no you know is she republican here's the
deal of course she is tina peters isn't
she the one and i don't want to speak
out of turn here but i believe this is
the [ __ ] [ __ ] that turned up at uh
mike lindell's uh little and and and
symposium last year that was supposed to
make us all convinced that the democrats
had stole the election donald trump was
actually king of the castle and somehow
the supreme court was going to overturn
some [ __ ] like that i don't know some do
you lose no [ __ ] she came in like the
second or third day she had to fly
around on a plane or some [ __ ] and the
reason why is because she had been
raided and obviously now we know why
she's being raided is because she was
committing federal crimes election
crimes jesus christ you can't they're
like oh don't don't worry i listen
the fbi and the police were at my place
but it's not for what you think it was
when really it is for what you think it
was right they actually accused them of
committing election fraud by by uh by
actually searching them is what they
were saying no no no that uh tina is i
think really tina peters accused the
feds and and the law enforcement
because she was saying oh you can't
you're not an election official you
can't handle the machines and you can't
like yeah dummy that's the problem
that's really the problem is because
you're committing election fraud now
they have to go get the tampered
machines and they're junk anyways
because you've tampered with them right
spiro agnew's ghost says here breaking
mesa counterclear a county clerk tina
peters and her deputy has been indicted
on a combined 17 counts for breach of
their own county's voter data so it
looks like um to break it down a little
more they were actually um
breaching their own county's data peters
is accused of leaking the data to
conspiracy theorists before giving a
speech at mike lindell's cyber symposium
so i was correct this is this is the
same tina peters that came to mike
lindell cyber symposium and she was
supposed to be the big evidence of why
why donald trump was still the king of
the castle meanwhile it turns out that
she was trying to make the evidence well
i wouldn't be surprised if we if mike
lindell the my pillow nazi enters the
chat here under federal indictments oh i
don't know i would totally expect him to
come in at some point right and i don't
know what
i've many questions for mike glendale
one how are you still
able to uh
i mean like are you making that much
money from my pillow i don't even know
but you know i look at this and i'm like
dude
he's i'm probably on a short list of
people that are by affiliation going to
be questioned and or
may be charged
now this was a couple weeks ago i don't
know if you remember but tina peters was
arrested a couple weeks ago and she was
kicking officers and calling them names
when she was being arrested why don't
you just comply just comply right
exactly but these are some still shots
of it um this person says tina peters
you can't arrest me i didn't do anything
wrong well
in an 11 count indictment says you
probably did
yeah allegedly 11 count indictment um
robin says here she downloaded
and shared the info so it looks like not
only was she illegally downloading and
copying the info she was sharing it with
mike lindell
which i don't know if that puts mike
lindell at legal risk or not i don't
know if he's like
if he's part of a conspiracy where he
was trying to get them to give him the
information i'm not sure pro fence also
says fency here says that's bobert's
congressional district um i'm thinking
that you're saying that the county
the county that this clerk is at in the
uh
in mesa county
uh colorado
is that mesa county colorado is one of
our part of
lauren bobert's district which also is
not surprising
um in that form and i believe i believe
those districts are being redistributed
so i don't know if the mesa county will
remain in that district or not because
colorado has a new map so yeah i did
want to bring that breaking news in
before we left we're 50 yeah for the
second hour um
let's see if we have um there's another
breaking
uh trend here stephanie grisham you
remember stephanie grisham is the former
uh white house press secretary said
trump loved the dictators he loved the
wait who is she
huh who she was a press secretary she
was yeah you remember when they weren't
having actual uh press uh press
briefings she was the press secretary
during that time between what but yeah
between huckabee sanders and um kaylee
mcenany oh well i didn't i guess i
didn't know because i never saw her
right because she never gave a press
briefing they shut them down they didn't
have press briefings
during that time um but vanity fair here
says uh the quote is from stephanie
grisham love the dictators he loved the
people who could kill anyone including
the press
this is the press secretary that is
saying this
right
now listen to what listen to my words
when i say this the former president
united states was saying in front of the
press secretary who is job it is to give
a national briefing for the office of
the president not the person right
office of the president to the free
press in this country so us as a people
understand what the white house and the
administration's and the office of the
president's position are on issues and
they have the transparency
to question those administration
officials the administration official
the press secretary the official person
who is in charge of briefing the press
is saying
that the president the former president
united states loved the dictators he
loved the people who could kill anyone
including the people who she would brief
is this in a book
she did she make a book a tell-all book
i i'm sure i'm sure she withheld this
for a book i'm sure she's gonna pop it
off this i'm almost sure of it let's see
what adolf twitter slayer says here did
you see the quote from the former white
house press secretary stephanie grisham
also i think trump admired putin greatly
i think he wanted to be able to kill
whoever spoke out against him and yet
the former guy still has support what
the [ __ ]
i mean literally literally the press
secretary is admitting here
he wants to be vladimir putin
this is not hyperbolic when we say it
here on the show
like when i say loves putin loves kim
jong-un right he loves the again we're
going back to the thing that we talked
about this morning which was he or
earlier today which is the fact that he
loves
those people
who
actually are dictators who actually are
like oh yeah kill that person uh silence
them uh take away this right you know
shut them down like the fact that he
actually wants
the power to be able to do that
and yet again like
he still has supporters people were like
oh he no no no joe biden is the real
tyrannical like dictator he's the one
who's controlling the government it's
like well this dude is openly saying he
loves the fact that these dictators are
able to kill people that he didn't like
especially the press because he doesn't
like the price because they sometimes
sounds like hitler right right so this
is apparently uh from the view this
morning i don't know if it's stephanie
grisham here but let's listen but my
point is now i messed up i am sorry i
will say that until then the end of oh
well you know
i actually i actually i actually believe
in a road of redemption but what i don't
believe in is when what what you're
saying because uh we were talking about
this yesterday i was talking about this
yesterday with brett about michael cohen
michael cohen he did he did write a book
but he did not save that stuff for his
book he went to congress he did it he
went to the d.a he he went and used he
told that information to the public to
make sure the public understood what
they were getting if they voted for
donald trump again that's admirable this
[ __ ] where they're holding information
for a book it's not admirable and i'm
sorry but i'm not sorry time but i want
to give people an offering and i'm going
to do everything i can to educate people
not talk down to them educate people
about who he really is yeah that he is a
con man that it is a cult-like thing and
that it's okay to just get off so you
would not get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] come on
like come on you know i you know for
people want to see the light and they
want to see that there was a con and a
grift and you finally admit to it cool
but again if you're going to take
advantage and try to profit
off of the [ __ ]
that you helped support the lies that
you helped spread
the misinformation that you that you
allowed to happen
and also just having a vile person who
literally said he was okay and like the
fact that you could kill you know any
any person who was against
you free press or whatever right but
here's the thing if she knew that if she
actually thought that when she was
standing there in front of that man
knowing that he would love to kill the
press as she's the press secretary and
she knows he's a con man and they want
an off-ramp why didn't you give the
country an off-ramp when you had the
duty right why didn't why did you wait
until right now right like we are we are
a year and a half
into after the [ __ ] big lie right
right right like or i guess less than a
year and a half but like what i'm saying
is
we are heading into our uh you know
we're heading to the midterms and we're
coming off of a you know a one year in a
month plus time of buying and being in
office you
you waited
until after you're out of this role as
press secretary which i was not even
aware of you waited until after the
election you waited until after the
insurrection you waited until after joe
biden became president you waited until
a year plus to now come out with some
sort of thing that you're probably gonna
profit off and say
oh well i'm trying to give people the
ability to see the con and get away from
this cult
where were you this whole time
like if this really was important to you
you wouldn't try to sell it you would
try to you try to give it away for free
you would get on your soapbox and you
would tell everyone who was willing to
listen i was duped i was conned and so
were you and it's okay to say that you
were right but if you're gonna get on
that soapbox and hawk a book or hawk uh
some sort of deal right whether it's a
show or something else to say hey guys
uh believe me i was wrong i was duped
but in order to really know the history
or really know the story or really know
how much was happening at the time buy
this thing and it's like no [ __ ] you the
[ __ ] out of here well and that and
that's the thing is that [ __ ] her and
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] them bill barr john bolton uh
stephanie grisham here
anyone anyone who held this information
from the american public who knew the
danger because i know what they're doing
now they're trying to they're trying to
profit and they're trying to make up uh
for the redemption as it were so they're
welcome back into society and um as long
as they're profiting off this
information um [ __ ] them we we shouldn't
welcome them
welcome back [ __ ] them [ __ ] every single
one of them
yep
[ __ ] them
so make sure uh we're 59 minutes an hour
we're running out of time here i
appreciate gabe you joined it for like
the whole show today i know the whole
show
we had jordi on go watch go download uh
legal af tonight the midas fam going
hard today right midas mighty was here
yeah so um so so uh
give give legal af a shout out when you
go to the chat tonight tell them you
heard jordy here refer yeah give a
referral in the chat that you heard
about the legal af tonight from jordy
here on the tony michaels podcast and
until tomorrow
until tomorrow serves up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking